from the new york post it says donald
glover he's a
well-known of course actor rapper uh
he tweeted over the weekend and this has
gotten a lot of reaction and
a lot of people are upset about it for
whatever reason
he tweeted quote um saw people on here
having a discussion about how tired they
were of reviewing boring stuff
tv and film we're getting boring stuff
and not even experimental mistakes
because people are afraid of getting
canceled
so they feel like they can only
experiment with aesthetic
also because some of them know they're
not that good
and then it goes on with the reaction to
that and of course people on the left
they don't like it when
they don't like it when you acknowledge
cancel culture and when someone that
they thought is on their side and really
any famous celebrity they assume is on
their side and most of them are
when they come out and start talking
about cancer culture it feels like a
betrayal and so that's the reaction that
donald glover has gotten
but but he's he's exactly right people
are
you know artists are afraid to
experiment afraid to try new things
and that's that's true that goes beyond
art though i think
one consequence of cancel culture
is that everything is boring
our discussion about issues
the debate on twitter and on social
media it's it's getting more and more
boring it's not as fun as it used to be
and a big reason for that is that people
are yeah they're afraid
of saying something that they know is
going to upset people
obviously because of cancer culture but
people are also afraid of experimenting
yeah artists are afraid to experiment
artistically
but i think people are people are afraid
to experiment with
ideas which is something that we should
encourage
we should encourage it especially in an
educational environment
in particular in uh in in the you know
so-called higher education
in academia we should encourage people
to kind of
you have an idea you're thinking through
something
you haven't thought it all the way
through you're not exactly sure
you know if you believe this or not but
it seems like an interesting thought on
this or that subject
and so you say it out loud and you kind
of start a conversation
and and ideally through that
conversation maybe you'll
you know your ideas start to firm up a
little bit more
and maybe ultimately you decide oh you
know what actually i'm not sure i really
believe that or maybe i'm wrong about
that
or you'll say yeah you know the more i
talk about this the more we talk about
it the more i realize i'm right about
what i said
that's the kind of thing that should be
encouraged it also makes conversation a
lot more interesting
but you certainly get almost none of
that in the school system and in
academia that is
very much frowned on frowned upon and
you don't get it out in society either
you don't get
much of much of it on social media
you don't get much of people just saying
hey i'm throwing this idea out there i'm
not even sure how much i feel about it
but it's an interesting thought that i
had
because isn't that a normal thing then
we all have you know sometimes you're
thinking about something
an interesting thought pops into your
head and you think to yourself
hmm i'm not actually sure is it uh you
know i don't know if that's right
exactly but it seems
it seems like an interesting perspective
on this issue
and i i assume i have those thoughts all
the time i assume most people do
but then you're afraid to say most
people are afraid to say it because they
know
if they don't have it exactly figured
out and fully formed and they're ready
to launch
an aggressive defense they're gonna get
eaten alive
and the consequence is one of the
consequences is that everything is just
kind of boring
people stick to you know
on every issue there are sort of
assigned opinions that you're supposed
to have whether you're on the right or
the left
and you know that if you're on the right
even if you even if you articulate one
of your assigned opinions
um there's still going to be a blowback
in many cases
but still you want to most people they
stick within that kind of
pre-approved framework and i think even
conservatives will say
okay well here's the issue gun rights
gender whatever it is
um these are kind of the opinions that
that most people on this side
seem to be expressing and so if i
express that
that point of view i know what kind of
blowback i'll get it's already
calculated it's already it's already
baked into the cake
but you're afraid to go beyond that and
to say oh you know what add another
thing here's another thought that i had
really is a tread it's it's it's a
tragedy um
because it makes not only everything
dull but it makes people into dull
thinkers listen hit that subscribe
button
right now do it right now i thank you
for your compliance
it is somewhat appreciated